[Music]
on this thursday night grief turns
to fury in beirut tonight chance
of revolution
as beirut buries its dead and pleads for
the world
to help allegations about a hit squad
how this former top saudi intelligence
official claims he was being hunted down
here in canada from death row to a new
life
the first woman convicted of blasphemy
in pakistan tells us her hopes and fears
in her new home in canada and a reminder
of the horrors
of nuclear weapons
[Music]
marking 75 years since the world's first
nuclear attack
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with stunning
allegations from the former top saudi
intelligence chief who now lives in
canada
he claims the crown prince of saudi
arabia sent a hit squad to track him
down
and kill him in canada because he knows
too much
the allegations are made in a civil
lawsuit filed in the united states these
are
allegations nothing's been proven in
court michael couture has been looking
through the lawsuit mike
take us through this well donna this
lawsuit was filed today in the u.s
federal court while we're not able to
verify the allegations in these court
documents
they are extraordinary the suit alleges
that saudi arabia's crown prince sent a
hit squad to canada
on a mission to kill a former top saudi
intelligence officer his name
is saad al-jabri he's a permanent
resident of canada
who now lives in toronto the suit claims
that his deep knowledge of the crown
prince mohammed bill
bin salman's business dealings make him
a target now in this suit
al-jabri's lawyers allege that a group
of elite hitmen known as a tiger squad
were sent to canada at the direction of
mbs
according to the court documents this is
the same group behind the 2018
killing and dismemberment of journalist
jamal khashoggi
at the saudi consulate in istanbul the
suit claims
members of that squad were stopped at
pearson an international airport
less than two weeks after khashoggi's
death attempting to enter canada on
tourist visas
carrying bags of forensic tools the plot
was allegedly thwarted
by canada border officers all men
refused entry except for one
he was let in with a diplomatic passport
and allegedly met with algebri
to pursue him to persuade him rather to
visit family in turkey
but el jabrie never went
mike all of this is stunning all these
allegations are stunning what is the
canadian government saying about it all
well public safety minister bill blair
wouldn't comment on the allegations but
he did say
quote it is completely unacceptable and
we will never tolerate foreign actors
threatening canada's national security
or the safety of our citizens and
residents now
relations between canada and saudi
arabia have been strained since august
of 2018
when then foreign affairs minister
christian freeland tweeted that the
kingdom
should immediately release imprisoned
protesters
but clearly relations weren't frosty
enough to stop the two countries from
signing
the 14 billion dollar deal this april
which will see canada sell the kingdom
light armored vehicles
donna all right michael couture in
ottawa thank you
the american president made a surprise
announcement today involving canada
donald trump says he's reimposing
tariffs on canadian aluminum
and that he signed a proclamation that
will put a 10 levy on raw aluminum
imports from canada
canada was taking advantage of us as
usual
and i signed it and it imposes because
the aluminum business was
being decimated by canada very unfair to
our jobs and
our great aluminum workers
steel and aluminum tariffs were first
imposed on canada in 2018 and then
removed last year as part of the new
nafta agreement which took effect in
july
some american metals companies have
complained canadian aluminum has flooded
the u.s market
shifting now to beirut a city broken a
city where the dead are being buried and
anger
is rising to the surface
[Music]
two days after a powerful explosion
flattened whole neighborhoods a
collective effort to clean up the
streets turned into a protest
people are fed up with government
corruption furious it appears negligence
led to the explosion lebanese officials
promised to investigate the cause but
few in beirut seem to trust them
people want new leadership and an
international investigation
into the blast
that's the french president emmanuel
macron he was in beirut today to tour
the destruction
and he was met with pleas for the world
to help macron says he supports an
independent probe into the blast and he
warns that without change
lebanon could run out of food and fuel
within months
lebanon has now begun an official period
of national mourning funerals are taking
place for the victims at least
137 people are now confirmed to have
died and more than 5 000
are injured there are fears others might
be found
under the rubble as crystal gomezing
reports there is no way
lebanon can recover from this on its own
they're chanting we will pay our blood
and soul for the sake of beirut
powerful words that speak to their
renewed determination
average people are focused on moving
forward
just days after their world was ripped
apart you can't keep living in sorrow we
cannot keep living
and we cannot keep depressed
we have to think on what to do fari
hadros is a lebanese canadian
he couldn't believe his eyes after the
blast but he has faith in his people
you know in lebanon like you we have
like each party each team each
uh community has their own
political views and all this we all put
all of this together
all on our side and we get united
but some are still angry the lebanese
justice minister was
heckled on the street and water bottles
tossed at her
the mood much different for the french
president
the student asked that he deal with the
corruption in lebanon
emmanuel macron is the first foreign
leader to visit following the explosion
lebanon is a former french colony he
told people
aid would get to those who need it and
that need is growing
we are now trying to see how we could
help the survivors
especially the people that they have
lost everything
and now they are displaced the port
where the blast originated was one of
the busiest in the eastern mediterranean
nearly all goods used in lebanon passed
through this site
it was also a hub for jordan syria iraq
and persian gulf states
some container liners are diverting
ships to lebanon's smaller port in
tripoli to keep
supply lines running other donated
supplies
are being flown in
there are reports the lebanese
government has given an investigative
committee
four days to determine who is
responsible for the deadly blast
crystal gamansen global news london
a woman who spent nearly 10 years on
death row in pakistan accused of
blasphemy has now found
safe haven here in canada and is telling
her story to global news
her name is asia bibi and what happened
to her triggered an international outcry
she's christian and she was convicted
after a long-standing dispute with
neighbors ended with a group
of local women accusing her of insulting
the prophet muhammad
for years she didn't know if she'd live
or die and then in 2018
pakistan's supreme court granted her
freedom she ended up
in canada we can't disclose the location
because there are still people
who want her dead
is making up for lost time
she's free and in a new home in canada
her two youngest daughters were just
eight and nine years old when she was
arrested
in pakistan
a farm worker and christian was accused
of arguing with local muslim women over
a cup of water
she was dragged away from her family and
became the first woman convicted
under pakistan's blasphemy laws she was
sentenced
to death her case was a lightning rod
pakistan is mostly muslim less than two
percent of people are christian
amnesty international has called for the
draconian blasphemy laws to be repealed
saying the accused are often presumed to
be guilty on the basis of little or no
evidence
and those who tried to help bibi paid
with their lives
in 2011 the governor of pakistan's
punjab province
was murdered after seeking a
presidential pardon for bibi
two months later a christian cabinet
minister who advocated for changes to
blasphemy laws
was shot and killed lawyer saif ul maluk
took on bibi's case in 2014. since 2011
i am under the police court along with
my family the
armed police officials the statement
showed out with me
wherever i go he brought her appeal all
the way to pakistan's supreme court
and in 2018 it overturned her conviction
but the joy was fleeting
[Music]
across the country there was outrage
thousands took to the streets
the motorway the all
highways of the country was closed
by these mullahs and the
religious people and the
country was stand still they demanded
bibi
and the judges be executed the only way
to save her was to get her out of the
country
her lawyer had to flee too quiet
negotiations began
and canada became the safe haven asha
bibi
who was persecuted for her faith is on
her way to canada
she lives a quiet life now with her
husband and daughters
in an undisclosed location cooking
cleaning and
gardening no longer a
government-sponsored refugee she admits
it's been difficult to make ends meet
she cannot speak english or french
and still fears an international
assassin could find her
and other lives are at risk too after
asia bb's freedom
our hope is quite boost of you can save
this man's sister and brother-in-law
have also been convicted under
pakistan's blasphemy laws
shagufta khausar and shafak emanuel
have been on death row since 2013.
this is how joseph who has asked us not
to use his last name
describes his sister's state of mind
very stressed
crying seeking for help begging please
for god's sake do something
to get me off i can't take it more i
can't take it more
he can't take it more this was her call
with the help of bibi's former lawyer
the couple is appealing their conviction
my
as for bibi she's grateful to canada for
her second chance at life
and hopes to be an advocate for
religious freedom
her three adult children and several
grandchildren still live in pakistan
and worry remains her constant companion
another canadian has been sentenced to
death in china on drug
charges court documents give few details
but local media are reporting
shuei hong was convicted of making and
storing ketamine
in a statement global affairs canada
says it's profoundly concerned
by the sentence and that canada opposes
the use of the death penalty in all
cases
canada is seeking clemency she was the
third canadian china has sentenced to
death on drug
charges after a deep decline in
relations between the two countries
canadians answering the calls for help
coming up how lebanese canadians are
doing all they can to help those in
beirut left
with nothing
canada is planning to support lebanon
providing five million dollars in
federal aid
for humanitarian assistance lebanese
canadians meanwhile continue to look for
other ways to help their homeland
rebuild while no formal fundraising
event has been launched
people have begun raising money for the
lebanese red cross
as camille caramalli reports with
lebanon's biggest port destroyed getting
goods into the country
is going to be a challenge
this is what remains of an apartment
less than a kilometer from the blast
site
in every room mangled metal destroyed
furniture
broken glass just that feeling that that
gut wrenching feeling
the home belongs to canadian jad al
tal's mother
he called her minutes after the
explosion happened the minute she
answered i just hear like screaming and
i'm like are you okay are you okay and
then she just said we're okay we're okay
what happened what happened
the deadly blast hits home for thousands
of lebanese canadians
halfway around the world the need is
immediate and anything we can do
anything anybody can do will be great as
soon as joe hamadi heard about the fatal
blast
he kicked off a fundraising campaign
vowing to match
every dollar raised less than 24 hours
after launch
it had collected more than a hundred
thousand dollars
going towards the lebanese red cross so
what does this say about the
lebanese-canadian community here you
know what we never expected this
but like i said people are very generous
the community is rallying across the
country
including twelve thousand dollars raised
by the lebanese club
of ottawa it made me proud to be
part of this country and to be canadian
the need for goods
is dire we need anything in lebanon
right now
and the list is long food equipment
medical equipment
just name it i have a big list but now a
major hurdle
the honorary consulate of lebanon in
toronto
has been trying to find ways to
transport donated goods to beirut
but with the country's biggest port now
looking like a war zone
the options are limited see if we can
get help
to airlift them or get like
with the boat we have a few other ports
that smaller size
hopefully they will accommodate those
boats and hope
is all anyone can hold on to while the
country tries to get back
on its feet camila caramali global news
still ahead a big announcement from nova
scotia's premier
you're watching global national
[Music]
the premier of nova scotia surprised
everyone today stephen mcneil announced
he's stepping down
he says the job has taken its toll on
him this year alone the province
suffered several tragedies including
deaths linked to covid19
and canada's deadliest mass shooting as
alexa mclean reports a public inquiry is
taking place into that
and mcneil's government could face
criticism
canada's longest serving premier says
he's been in the job long enough
first elected in 2003 stephen mcneill
has been nova scotia's premier since
2013
leading two liberal majority governments
17 years is a long time i love this job
i've enjoyed every day of it and every
day i'm inspired by the people of this
province
but this is not a lifelong career his
resignation comes as a surprise to many
but
mcneil says it's something he says he's
been contemplating
for some time in a prepared speech
mcneal thanked nova scotians for
sticking together
during a tumultuous year through the
deaths and hardships brought on by covet
19
and the grief and pain caused by april's
mass killings
that took the lives of 22 innocent
people
mcneil says nova scotians have shown
faith in each other
our province has experienced the one
tragedy after another and we've seen a
lot of death
families have suffered in measurable
loss and it is my hope that the
generosity of others
and the support from fellow nova
scotians will continue to help heal
broken hearts
scrutiny is expected to be placed on the
police and government response to the
april killings in an upcoming public
inquiry
mcneal has said he's committed to its
search for answers mcneal says he
doesn't know what he'll do after leaving
public office he'll continue to lead the
province until the nova scotia liberals
hold an election race and elect his
successor
the party has until 2022 to hold a
provincial election
alexa mclean global news halifax
the horrors of nuclear war up next
lessons from the attack on hiroshima
this photo this mushroom cloud is as
menacing today as it was 75 years ago
it was taken about an hour after the
enola gay dropped a nuclear bomb over
the japanese city of hiroshima
the world had never seen anything as
horribly powerfully destructive
at least 70 000 people were killed
immediately
just their shadows left behind that was
august 6
1945 another 70 000 people died in the
weeks after from radiation exposure
cancer and other long-term effects
killed tens of thousands more
three days later the us dropped a second
nuclear bomb on nagasaki
as eric sorenson explains it still is
searing a cautionary tale
about the horrors of nuclear war
the bell tolls and the sound lingers
compelling reflection on the horror of
hiroshima
and nagasaki attendance at this year's
somber ceremony limited by covet 19
and because there are fewer survivors 75
years on
tarumi tanaka recalls the white blast at
nagasaki
he was 13.
the all-shattering devastation in which
was born the atomic age
tanaka remembers the dead the
destruction and the suffering from
radiation that would go on for years
he spent a lifetime speaking out against
nuclear weapons
activism must continue says tanaka on a
treaty to destroy and ban the world's
nuclear arsenal
generations of nuclear nations have
avoided the consequences of mutually
assured destruction but among nine
countries there remain more than
thirteen thousand nuclear weapons in the
world
each one of them is far far more
sophisticated destructive than those
two crude primitive one used
on my city setsuko thurlow's city was
hiroshima
she is japanese canadian and an
outspoken survivor
she's campaigned for greater awareness
of canada's crucial role in uranium
mining and research that was part of the
manhattan project
that built the first atom bomb in the
second world war
in the globe and mail this week thurlow
called on the prime minister to issue a
public expression of regret for canada's
role in the development of nuclear
weapons
three years ago thurlow accepted the
nobel prize for peace on behalf of the
international campaign
to abolish nuclear weapons hers a strong
voice
among a shrinking number of survivors
it's a lonely feeling
we have to support each other to survive
in this world today
thurlow's home hiroshima was annihilated
a prediction at the time was that
nothing would grow in hiroshima for 75
years
in fact a city vibrant and hopeful has
risen from the utter destruction
the mayor of hiroshima today called his
community a symbol of peace
and an enduring reminder of a painful
experience
that must never be allowed to repeat
itself eric sorensen global news
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is orkney
viewpoint in knee hill county alberta
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye-bye